[Music]
i grew up on a farm in
this region ninth generation of farmers
growing up between cows and
beef bulls and arable farmer
and from 1997 i had my organic
farm
the finer netherlands millions of
pigs were killed because of parks plague
he johan they asked me  to store
a dead pigs the cold store a
bit from moments to think about it
even more consciously and
to choose to become a vegetarian
then I found out the hardest part is
the meat no further will now my meat
last address
well that will be  actually the reason
for the sweeping ice layers
the problem with her the meat production
the large scale we use that
animal as production machines many
people still have mixed feelings
about eating
meat this way but yes we like it so much
and that was for me  also the reason
to try to make vegetable meat
vegetarian meat without light
achieved
with love onion  twageningen delft started their
eight years ago to develop a real
meat machine and
then in combination with chef with
top butchers who
prepared that meat structure
you eat vegetable meat cooked
marinated to come to that really the
meat experiences
the cleaning brush yes
hopefully  also really lucky
and because my new ideas also
technology to make those beans that
did that structure of meat
and that the innovative that succeeded and
that was special because they
did a small team we did our last
year  restaurant open meat lobby
and the restaurant people can experience
how the optimal range
tastes but you really can keep a pale very well
yes that to dust those gyros through the
required mirror se the coupon against
livestock farming again we contribute louis of
25 cents to  the greenhouse gas problem
so that moment we can
replace that with vegetable remains and
stuck more effect because we all a
would take cars off the road
I think that's possible
yes it's a nice initiative and we
just want to make people aware
that you don't have to have meat every day
my dream is that we minimize our impact
as people that
we  meat in our dairy products is
directly plant-based, which takes up much less
space on this earth
[Music]